hello i'm greg sadler the editor of
stoicism today a member of the modern
stoicism team and one of the organizers
this year for
stoicon the world's largest annual
gathering of people interested in
stoicism both in its ancient and modern
forms and i want to tell you all about
it first of all i want to give you a
save the date so it's coming up a little
under two months from my talking to you
right now on october
9th that's a saturday and it's going to
be an online event again this year so
you don't have to travel to get to it
you can mark it on your calendar and you
don't have to worry about jostling with
anybody else to get into a packed room
we are going to have enough room for as
many attendees as want to show up last
year it was over a thousand people who
were there for the event virtually and
we'll probably have even more this time
so once again on saturday october 9th
put it on your calendar we are going to
have an eventbrite
event page that will allow you to sign
up for it and and purchase a ticket
purchasing means actually just making a
donation this year just as last year
we'll also be having an announcement
post shortly in stoicism today the
official blog of the modern stoicism
organization that is putting on stoicon
and we're going to have a lot of other
stuff coming up in stoicism today
including interviews with some of the
speakers and other announcements about
cool things related to stoicon and stoic
week so stay tuned
for all of that all those follow-ups i
would like to mention
my other
fellow organizers and co-organizers so
andy shaka and i
have taken on the task of the main
organization we are ably assisted by
phil yanov and harold kavli and a whole
host of other people that will be
working behind the scenes to provide a
really great and engaging experience for
you and an opportunity to not only learn
about stoicism but connect with other
people that are interested in that
tickets will be available on the
eventbrite site as i mentioned it's
donations so you know you give what you
think you
ought to give or what you would like to
give and everybody has different income
levels
so you don't have to feel bad if you if
you can't give anything we're still
happy to have you there if you want to
give a big donation that's great too all
of the proceeds will be going to the
modern stoicism organization a
non-profit that puts on stoicons
supports stoic on x's provides stoic
week provides a whole bunch of other
online seminars and classes all
dedicated to
helping people learn about and apply
ancient philosophy
in their modern lives so on the day of
the event there will be a zoom link that
gets sent to everybody who has tickets
so you don't have to ask about that
ahead of time that'll all be made
available
at the at the right time i do want to
give a short bit of history before
telling you about how the event is set
up this year
so
we're almost approaching a decade of
stoicons which is a really cool thing to
be able to say it started out in london
with a you know a kind of informal but
still structured meeting of philosophers
psychotherapists a few other people that
actually got some attention and it was
connected with live like a stoic week
and then it grew and became
something that we identify as
stoicon the world's largest gathering of
stoics and people interested in stoics
in history and it grew every year at
first it was taking place in london then
it went across the atlantic to new york
then it was in toronto back to london
again then to athens greece and then of
course
coronavirus hit and we had to go online
and we had an even bigger event last
year in 2020
entirely virtual so we decided to do
that again this year because not only
you know can we not predict what's going
to happen with the coronavirus but it
offered the opportunity
to engage people
worldwide in a way that the main
physical face-to-face conference
although it was great
wasn't actually able to do so we're
really happy to have anybody who wants
to come and participate we have a lot of
great speakers
lined up um we're making it even more
interactive this year we've been putting
a lot of thought and planning
into that we've got five talks which
will be anywhere from you know 20 15 to
20 minutes each with some q a
afterwards we've got speakers talking
about a whole variety of different
subjects so that's kind of the
traditional thing we also have a great
keynote coming up with nancy sherman so
that's something that i'm really looking
forward to but we have two
panels and ask the expert panel where
you get to contribute the questions all
be moderating and our experts
will be answering the questions for you
some of them will be provided ahead of
time by people and some of them will
take from the audience right there and
then
we're also going to have another panel
about applying stoicism with experts in
those sorts of fields ranging from
parenting to mindfulness to all sorts of
things in between
we're going to have a workshop led by
tim labon
which will have him providing us with
some guidance and content and then we'll
go into breakout rooms and we'll do work
together there and then come back as a
community and
share our results with each other and
we're also going to have lightning talks
this is a very popular feature that we
did in the past this year they will be
pre-recorded harold covley will be
emceeing that and and overseeing it and
that is a big treat as well it's a way
in which many people can get to speak
for a short amount of time these are
lightning talks you know three to five
minutes at a time those are a lot of fun
as well so we have all of that lined up
speakers are going to be coming and
zooming in from three different
continents it's going to be an all-day
affair the speakers include academics
therapists popular writers coaches
journalists many of them are members of
the modern stoicism team including some
recent additions but we have a whole
bunch of other people as well you'll be
able to go to the eventbrite page i'll
also put a you know sort of a
description of the different talks and
panels and things like that with the
speakers names in the video description
so you can go there as well and look for
the post coming out uh in stoicism today
and updates about stoicon as well and
don't forget stoicon comes before stoic
week another main event put on by modern
stoicism that you can participate in
we're going to be revamping it again
this year so lots of cool opportunities
for you to learn practice and engage
with others about stoicism
you